that is so great to see all of you I'm
recognizing so many faces here it's
gonna be hard not to just look up and
say hi like the politicians wave I'm not
gonna do that I want to make a couple of
remarks before I invite our guests to
join me on stage we started talking
about the reunion at the end of last
year and said you know people come to
visit school for three reasons one is
the imprimatur of a great university
second which you've already gotten you
got your degrees second is because the
associations that you all make with one
another and the third reason is really
for to learn and to be inspired and it's
for that third reason that we're met
here in Bishop today and I think as you
go around and see people in your class
in these black t-shirts or staff members
in red ones please thank them for all of
the efforts that have gone on weekly
meetings since January to put this
together so for the next 80 minutes what
we're gonna do is I'll make a couple of
brief introductions I'm not gonna say
much because I'm going to let Kent and
John introduce themselves and ask them
to each take five or ten minutes and
just talk a little bit about their lives
careers philosophy of leadership
anything they'd like to talk about and
then we'll have a Q&A period
that'll be organized which means that
we've collected questions from you we've
put them in categories we're and I'll
try to kind of group them and and talk
to them just have a casual chat up here
on stage and then disorganized which the
disorganized portion or questions from
the audience on anything you want to ask
them I've cleared this with them they
feel confident they can handle you so
we'll see I will tell you one quick
little story in the in the leadership
perspectives class I've used this
getting somebody like Kent we've had
Kent in twice in the leadership
perspectives class and I've used that as
a hook to bring in other people so when
I talked to John I said you know John
Kent's been in a couple of times whether
you should class you know you might
think about that and so this is really
the dry run we're gonna he's going to be
testing you to see whether or not he'll
actually come in so I'll be able to tell
how this
goes we got we got Roger Staubach to
agree this next year to come in based on
the fact that we had Steve Young the
year before and we were a hooker in and
the same thing with we think we're gonna
get general Myers who's the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs to come in based on the
fact that John Abizaid came in two years
ago so Kent is the hook to bring John in
we'll see how this goes now so he'll be
testing you so do your best
we asked the committee who in the world
would you like to have come so if you
could pick anybody in the world who
would you like to have then force rank
them and these two or at the top of the
list we thought we're going to get a lot
of noes so we better get the invitations
up they both said yes so what do you do
with that and we decided let's see if we
can get them both on stage at the same
time wouldn't that be unique once the
last time we had two CEOs from fortune
500 companies on the same stage
it was probably testifying before the
Senate
we were told that we'd never fill bishop
we've filled bishop other than a couple
of seats down here and we have some
overflow rooms there's been a great
turnout for this 600 people signed up to
come to this these companies represent
over 15 billion in sales and 50,000
employees a small city and indeed Kent
goes by the title of mayor we'll learn
more about that later so I want to show
a couple of slides before we get into
this Johnny do you have slides there
let's put the first slide slide up there
so there's an interview recently with
John Donahoe but New York Times in April
that was entitled there's no need to bat
900 and the quote is all you have to do
is hit one single a couple of doubles an
occasional homerun of every 10 at-bats
and you're going to be the best hitter
or the best business leader around so
slide 2 then Johnny is based on this is
what I've called the theory success
constant of 0.7 0 0 and let me show you
in slide 3 how this is calculated which
is basically the slugging percentage so
this is the part you come here to learn
and to be inspired this is the learning
part so you can't go home and say I
didn't learn anything at the reunion
this is what baseball aficionado is
called a slugging percentage so if you
get one single x one 2 doubles x 2 Kent
doesn't allow for any triples so that's
0 and then if you had a home run every
15 times at bat which is kind of what
the hitters who hit 30-plus homers a
year do good hitters that you end up
with a slugging percentage of 700 so how
many major leaguers today have a
slugging percentage of 7 are just shout
it out this is Stanford this is not that
other business school 0 with some really
savvy crowd I thought I'd at least get
some how about in the past though when
you had the great the great players and
not as good at pitching ball part still
ever how many a couple three four ok put
up the fourth slide giant
so here they are this is all time
hitters nobody has ever hit theories
constant for success ever so he says all
you have to do is you don't have to bet
well he's talking about 700 slums and
nobody's ever done it so I want you to
know that when I came when I was
interviewing I asked to tell people look
if you get a hit get a single one every
three times you'll be in the Hall of
Fame if I had had the theory constant
when I was in issues he would be
interviewing me rather than the other
way around so the quick introductions
John Donahoe graduated from Dartmouth in
82 went to work for Bain interrupted his
time at Bain to get an MBA here he was
rehired at Bain by Kent theory and
they've remained friends and mutual
admirers ever since he's since gone on
to become the San Francisco Managing
Partner then the worldwide Managing
Partner of Bain 29 offices 3,000
employees he's now the CEO of eBay after
Meg Whitman one quick story about John
that'll give you some insight and he'll
he'll tell more about his story but when
he was dating his wife present wife
Eileen he was busy working for Bain and
she said is this really the life you
want with this kind of travel stress
pressure and everything he said no it's
not the life I want he wrote on the back
of a Shawmut bank receipt this is not
the life as a consultant is not the life
I want he signed his name to it and gave
it to her she put it in his person one
of the questions for you is how many
times is she had to bring that out years
and the reason I relate to this story is
because I told my wife if she would only
marry me I would learn how to dance and
20 years later she bought dancing
lessons for us and I said you know I
never told you when to which she
responded I knew you should have gone to
law school so John actually signed the
thing and gave it to his wife so we'll
get the answer to that but he's dealt
with tough business experiences
turnarounds and I want him to talk a
little bit about how you how you do that
so he'll talk to us about that one of
the the
the Businessweek I wrote an article when
he first took over called CEO survivor
edition calling his first days as CEO
hell they're so we'll get him to talk
about that but since hitting a low at
the end of last year the eBay stock has
doubled so was I can't he not only
graduated undergraduate from Stanford
but his wife is on the board of trustees
here so he stays close to Sam we won't
talk about his incomprehensible decision
to go to that other business school I
know as Garth will not pronounce the
name of that but since he does have a
700 slugging percentage the stock of De
Vita has gone up 26 fold since he's
taken on his the role of CEO a couple of
quick things just story from a story
standpoint when we have him in a
leadership perspective class we
constantly get the the review that he is
such an intentional leader he is so
focused things then last year one of the
comments was wow just wow so I'm gonna
read to you finally before we invite
them on stage what a recent alum said
about cancel your ship I often think
about him and I'm humbled by one of
Kent's favorite quotes about leadership
in life this is not a dress rehearsal
this is your life this person goes on to
say as a young leader at divita I've
experienced that leadership development
here is not just about learning how to
be a good leader it is about learning
how I need to live my life not tomorrow
when I have time more time or energy but
today because my life and the lives of
those I serve depends on it so with that
let's welcome these two leaders up
so I'm just going to ask you to stand up
and talk about leadership and life and
anything you want to then we'll turn
over to John and then we'll interview
both thank you
it's an honor to be here and in
particular in honor to be here with John
whom I recruited perhaps the best thing
I ever did for Bain was to recruit him I
try to look over the fact that he then
ruthlessly pushed me out and his way to
that this was five years out for a whole
bunch of you so for me five years out
from Business School which was that
other one was 1988 and so I was at Bain
then my wife was in venture capital and
we had just had our first baby and so I
was it was a time when having that first
baby and being it that's that stage of
our career where we're life with the new
baby became a hundred times more
wonderful and it became a zillion times
more difficult and it was also that
stage from a career point of view that I
was really trying to figure out it I was
plan on becoming a partner and then
doing a lateral transfer and going out
and working in an operating company that
always been the plan and it was at that
stage you start to think about okay what
is the right path to to do that so
that's the juncture I was at and so I
tried to I tried to think about back
when I was at that time and in that
place what sort of things would have
been useful for someone potentially to
say to me so I wouldn't have made all
the horrendous mistakes I proceeded to
make or their subsequent many years the
end as I talked about some of these
subjects because I'm trying to try to
hit quickly at life leadership work-life
balance in six minutes
the I speak with the full cognizance
that many of you are probably better
practitioners in all those categories
and I am what I have been is a very
serious student of those areas and so I
bring to you the fruits of my
observations which is many the divita
people over here will attest it not
necessarily correspond with my behaviors
so on the life side I think when one
sits back and says I aspire to a
fulfilling and fun life and I want that
in the context of working in the
for-profit sector because
in some ways you can say that's that's
easier if you take the non-for-profit
path so what does the answer how does
one lead a virtuous life virtuous not in
the sense that you go out of a day at
lunch and and give free meals to the
homeless although you you may do that
but virtuous in a more conventional
for-profit setting how do you lead a
virtuous life virtue defined as living
in a life that's aligned with your own
values I wit which highly personalized
there's no easy answer to that the only
answer is your own and John and I have
both had so many friends who have lost
their way over time we have a lot I'm 54
and a lot of people who are well-to-do
and very unfulfilled at this age because
they didn't reflect enough on this along
the way what was alignment for them and
two of the quotes that we use at divita
where we try to grow not business
leaders but life leaders one was already
cited by whatever person wrote that
comment and we've used it for ten years
that this is not a dress rehearsal this
is your life you really don't get a
do-over every time does pass pretty
quickly and then you're as old as I am
and so you really want to leave the
examined life and it's easy to slip into
a pattern where you're racing so fast
you you don't the second quote is a it's
a Buddhist quote begin with the end in
mind if you can't if you can't cite if
you can't write down what you want your
life to be like X years from now in any
kind of specificity with any kind of
clarity so that's a useful guide for
making decisions then you probably don't
have enough clarity for it to guide your
behaviors and decisions in fact that
some of this stuff is not obvious there
are in fact a lot of significant Forks
that one takes the only difference is
whether they're conscious or unconscious
and a lot of folks are in the
unconscious category that's a non-life
now under leadership and all of this is
more to provoke rigorous questions in
the Q&A session from you and Joe and
others a lot four five thoughts on on
leadership one is that management is a
business skill I'm going to get better
at management you'll learn more about
business business practices leadership
is a human skill trying to get better at
literate leadership learn more about
humans most particularly yourself
leadership thought number two just as
Duty is in the eye of the beholder
leadership is in the eyes of the lead it
literally does not matter one bit what
kind of leader you think you are
it only matters what leader others
experienced you to be and if you don't
have the courage and skill to solicit
that feedback the gift of that feedback
and work on it in a transparent way then
you will never be the leader that you
might think you are leadership thought
number three leadership is not a
function of position it is a function of
behavior and therefore never think that
well once I get to be VP once I get to
be partner once I get to be Dean once I
get to be then I'm really gonna lead you
know right now I'm sort of oppressed by
the system and the norms and my boss and
the rest and so I'm gonna lead then
that's not what leaders do that's not
what leaders do obviously there are
limits as to the impact you can have but
there are not limits as to the behavior
that you can demonstrate and the ripples
effect of that at any position can be
quite significant leadership thought
number four a lot of stuff that gets
written about leadership talks about
what leaders do know that the techniques
the practices the tactics the approaches
from my experience leadership is much
more about what you are and how people
experience what you are and any set of
techniques and practices virtually any
set of techniques and practices can work
based on their assessment of what you
are as opposed to what you do and the
fifth and final point about leadership
is that if you aspire to being a life
leader a strong business leader in the
sense of creating work environments
which are more fun fulfilling and
effective than the norm by a good margin
and then you go to places to work where
leadership is valued where it's
discussed where it's studied where it's
honored where it's rewarded if you want
to be great at marketing you go
someplace we're going to work for people
and with people that are great at
marketing
you're great at strategy go someplace
that you're great at finance it go
someplace where they're great at it may
get a lot of people who say they want to
be leaders and they go to places that
don't have a leadership bone in their
body
not a strand of leadership in their DNA
and they go there with that professed
goal it just doesn't make sense
enough fun leadership often to culture
building here if you want to build a
distinctive team a distinctive culture
whether you're running a department a
geographic area or a company or running
some sort of non for-profit
not-for-profit affiliation or some
political group requiring creating a
distinctive culture a sustainably
distinctive culture taked requires the
same kind of strategic and operating
discipline as figuring out a corporate
strategy or rolling out a new product
line it takes clarity it takes
intellectual clarity it takes clear
allocation of responsibilities
it takes meticulous metrics and
follow-through that's that's what it
takes when you hear people talk about
the kind of culture they want to create
and then you ask them well gosh every
month how much time you spend on labor
well they go what's a no-brainer I've
got reports on labor we have monthly
meetings or Awards tied to it you ask
them do you track the sales of a new
product rolled out well of course we do
that it's a dumb question we have
reports we have meetings we brainstorm
and say okay now how do you do in
tracking your culture and whatever word
you want to put on it and they stop so
well that sort of happens automatically
and we have some stuff on the walls and
we know and then we give a speech so
we'll know that that can't be if you
want have something distinctive in an
area of human behavior which is the
trickiest area of all then you've got to
be incredibly purposeful in relentless
we ever saying it divita that we want to
be a community first and a company
second that we want to be a community
that just happens to be organized in the
form of a company and of course people
at community want their their village
which is what we're called the divita
village and I'm the mayor they want it
to be economically successful everybody
gets that but you want to behave along
the way as if you're in a community I'll
leave that one I guess maybe one other
point on that that everybody at some
point goes through a pretty fundamental
philosophical fork in the road if you if
you're thoughtful on some of this stuff
which is what does the means and what is
the end and this can get tricky between
family and career and what type of
career and you can get tricky within a
company has to be your behavior when I
ran my first company I was regarded as a
as a strong team builder and a strong
positive culture but for me all that was
the means it was sincere it was the
means in the end was a hired stock price
my current company it is different it
took me a year or two to realize it was
different it wasn't a conscious
intellectual decision but for me that
means and the ends had flipped that the
means was having adequate profit and
shareholder return in an ER support the
end of creating a distinctively
fulfilling and rewarding work place for
thousands of human beings doesn't mean I
have been successful but I'm
that flip it turns out the overlap in
the activities whether whether the
team-building is the means or the
community is the end that there's a huge
overlap in the activities but there's a
dramatic difference in the texture of
those activities and the impact that
those same behaviors have when I think
about culture building and leadership
one of the phrases now I use more and
more as I get older is that
intentionality rules that people can
smell your intentionality and so you've
got to think a lot about what it is
whether you're giving a performance
review terminating someone or talking to
your team about what kind of culture you
want to have people smell your
intentionality then on work-life balance
that the only point I'll make here and
more stuff might go on in QA is if you
do not bring the same sort of analytical
rigor to engineering your life as you do
to engineering a factory or a cost
structure or a promotional strategy then
you will almost certainly fail because
all the pressures and distractions and
complexities are as intense and as
numerous and so many people get sucked
into that abyss where they're working
too much and experienced rest every week
because they've not brought the same
intellectual rigor to evaluating the
engineering of their life that they have
to their business problems and then once
they get married and start having kids
they can never quite catch up in the
same way if you never organized the
factory right and you're just every week
racing on an ad-hoc basis to meet quota
you're never going to have a great
factory and I'll close by just saying
two things then the what what we believe
is that if you want to lead to someplace
special
it's important that you speak your dream
out loud even knowing that when you
first do it a lot of people in the crowd
will be looking at you saying that's not
authentic that's not sincere
that's not thoughtful that's not
plausible that's not realistic it's not
what I care about but absent the rigor
of speaking it out loud since most human
beings that they say something I want to
live up to it you'll tend to climb a
hill instead of
and then and finally another quote we
use a lot to help guide us along the way
is Buddha's saying it is easy to be
mindful it is hard to remember to be
mindful part of the job of a leader is
to make sure that the human beings that
work for him or her are as mindful as
high percentage of the time as is
humanly possible thank you
so this is a special day for me it's a
special partly because it's my 50th
birthday but what is making my 50th
birthday even more special is I get to
be on the same stage with talking about
leadership with the single leader who's
had the biggest impact in my life and
Joel talked about following Kent into
your classroom well I followed Kent my
whole career because Kent hired me at
Bain Kent was my boss for the first
three years Kent has been a mentor
friend inspiration and for those you all
work for Divya to know he's also
probably the most exceptional leader
I've ever seen in terms of just hands-on
leadership so Kent it's a wonderful a
wonderful way to spend my 50 now the
problem for all of you is because I have
followed him what I had to say is
exactly the same it's different words I
sitting this morning thinking all right
what should I say well I'm gonna think
about things that would be would have
been useful for me on my fifth reunion
and I'm going to do three things cuz I
learned from kit everything's in threes
right now the difference in Kent and I
is Kent told you his I'm gonna ask
questions so I'm gonna suggest three
questions that you might want to be
thinking about at this stage your lives
about leadership in about your life the
first how do you find meaning reason I
ask that is my experience is that the
hardest thing and the most important
thing is to link the activities of your
life to something that gives you
meaning now I learned this from my
leadership role models my father was the
first and my father exude 'add service
he was a he worked for Price Waterhouse
service and a belief that the way he
could give service is to bring the best
out in other people didn't matter what
he was doing that gave him meaning that
gave him allowed him to put his head on
the pillow every night ken was my second
role model Kent exudes as you guys know
building a team taking the hill that
it's not just where you're going but
it's how you go through it the journey
you go through and in particular Kent
loves it when there's adversity he used
to talk about its 2nd down and 40 and we
got to get to be at first we got to get
to a first down and that's when he was
at his best and that gave him meaning it
just third mentor for me Tom Tierney who
Kent and I both work for Tom exude a
belief in people's full potential and
and and and having a long term view in
mine so I had some great role models to
try to figure out what gives me meaning
and here's it there's no right or wrong
answer to what gives you meaning and
only you can figure it out because each
of us is different for me it's I want to
be part of building great and enduring
organizations when the book built to
last came out by Jerry Porras it was a
wonderful professor for me here it
captured for me
and it's not only about what we
accomplished but it's with whom I
accomplished it and how we accomplished
it
note some similarities from my mentor
and I've been blessed that most of my
career I could link my activities
selling consulting hours being in an
Internet company that's hot that's not
that's this that's that didn't matter to
me because my energies I dedicated those
organizations gave me a sense of purpose
and meaning and it made the short term
success or failure a little less
important in the moment so first
question encourage you to think about is
what gives you meaning second what is
your
life journey and are you conscious of it
here are some similarities I was
thinking this morning five years out of
Stanford I was working for Kent and I
wanted to make partner at Bain and I was
I was impatient because I thought it was
time you remember this we're working on
environment slug that was boning on Kent
he was a partner what am I gonna make
partner what am I gonna make partner and
he says well you got to go talk to Tom
Tierney the guy that was running the
firm and so I go into Tom and say Tom
it's about time I want to make partner
it's not it's not fair it's right it's
been five years Tom in his infinite
wisdom kind of chuckled
he said yeah okay let's just set that
aside for a minute John Owen what I want
to do two things 100 here's a piece of
paper I want you to write down what you
want written on your tombstone what I
want here to talk about partner no no no
he said I will talk about at the end so
I write down what I wanted my tombstone
he said great
he said Holly I said 30 I think I was 30
or 29 again he said how long do you want
to be actively engaged in in the world I
said tell I'm 75 he said great so you've
only got 45 more years then he drew out
a piece of paper and he put 75 through
65 65 through 55 55 through 45 45 to 35
and he said how old are your kids I had
two at the time at 4 now and I wrote out
he said this is where your kid's gonna
be in high school this is when they go
off to college here's where you and your
wife are going to be empty nesters
here's where you're going to be have
intense periods of family he said what's
your wife what's her career in birth
ambitions and where does that fit he
said what's your family situation who
are your friends and he mapped it out he
said my real question for you is given
you've got only 45 years left in your
career what do you want to accomplish
each decade that moves you towards a
tombstone so we go in a conversation
around that and all of a sudden at the
end of that conversation whether I got
promoted to partner in the next month
didn't seem quite so important and so
having intentionality is Kent called it
about your own life's journey and again
there's no right or wrong answer for a
life's journey
it's only yours the hard part is
figuring it out third question how will
you keep learning my mode for learning
changed right about when I was in your
stage and actually Kent's involved in
this story as well five years out of
business school because I had in college
in a business school I had this image
that the way I wanted to learn is I
wanted to find this yoda-like mentor I
would sit at their knees and just absorb
the wisdom right just just learn and
they would teach me about everything
about business about life about
leadership and Kent was one of those
early figures for me as was Tom Tierney
as were my father or a few Stanford
professors and write about five years in
working for Kent I started realizing
that actually I was a little better than
he was at some things and and that I was
a little better than Tom Tierney that
some things not everything but it's some
things so all sudden I said well Who am
I going to learn from because I got to
find someone that's bad you know that's
better at everything and what I began to
realize is actually know at some point
your career there's no one that's better
at everything probably and I guarantee
you you're there and so I had changed my
mode of learning from learning a lot
from one person to learning a little
from a lot of people and it has
completely changed my orientation around
learning I learned something from every
interaction I have with someone because
everybody's good at something
in fact I've trained my mind that I go
into any meeting and I walk out and I
had this hilariously recurring
experience where I'll walk out of a
meeting at eBay with you know we're
negotiating some deal and our CFO was
like god they were such and I
said well no I thought he was really
good at this and I thought this guy was
really good at that because I look for
what they're good at because what I can
learn from and I'm constantly learning
as a result and so my question for you
is how are you going to keep learning
throughout not just the next five to ten
years but the next twenty five years and
have intentionality around it so I
that we almost said the same thing so
I'll ask you to consider those three
questions and look forward to continuing
the conversation so we can almost
adjourn the meeting here we could
certainly turn it over to questions here
but a couple of things I've heard can't
talk about you know how leadership is
learned and yet when you and I were
sitting there talking and watching him
we had this conversation about how he's
such a natural he is a charismatic
leader it's just he's an leadership
Beeler have you learned leadership are
you able to train leaders are you able
to take raw clay and mold it should
everybody in here think they have
leadership ability or are some people
naturals well it might be clear about
one thing
Kent's a natural leader but he had to
learn a lot and I was one of his betas
and and the reality is Kent cared
Kent was not the easiest guy to work for
he was a charismatic leader but he was a
pain in the ass right you weren't you
were one oh you got last yeah but but
what part of what make makes even an
even a natural leader like Kent has to
really really work at it and I think
that's if there's one common thread
about good leaders is they never quit
learning they never quit wanting to get
better and so you know I think the term
natural leader is a little over overused
because we get to deal with a lot of
CEOs now or world leaders or political
leaders and to me one of the common
denominators charisma actually sort of
maybe make some a difference in on TV
for the politicians but I think in
business what makes the best leaders so
the ones that never quit wanting to
learn yeah
and and they're their personalities are
as different as can be so I don't know
if you could teach it but I do know what
can be learned so Kent you know as you
Kent is known to dress up in three
musketeers gear and get out and play the
mayor role and I mean here's a lot of
fun as you've watched your buddy
at eBay
should be booed in meetings and have I
mean he has had a tough row to hoe
I mean Bear Stearns was on the rocks the
time he at the time he took over one of
the toughest in memory he's really had a
tough thing do you what advice would you
give it what or what have you seen him
do that yeah I think I did talk with
John stepped into eBay was a very
difficult situation on a number of
levels including the fact that he hadn't
been out of bein an at eBay that long so
a lot of domain knowledge and networking
relationships within your own
institution he didn't have the benefit
of that in addition to the fact that
business was going south and was highly
highly visible and a lot of people were
losing a lot of money so we talked to
every now and then and I think I gave no
useful advice but was heartened by the
fact that this is this is when you find
out who a leader is really it's it is
easy to lead when things are going well
yeah it's easy to behave well when
things are going well
it is hard now but for a leader the
beautiful thing is when things are lousy
everybody's paying attention to you
alright so the way I think the metaphor
I use it's the equivalent of Super Bowl
commercials cost for two million dollars
for 30 seconds or some most expensive
why because everybody's watching and
listening that's why it's so expensive a
crisis like he inherited the bad thing
is it's a crisis the good news is
everybody's listening and watching and
so if you're going to demonstrate
important stuff whatever that is you're
going to move more minds and have more
people think and feel a certain way then
you will ever get the opportunity again
because they will not be listening so
much again and I think this is what he
got and did you couldn't guarantee what
the business outcome was going to be but
within the context of whatever that
business outcome was going to be it was
going to be a healthier organization and
in the end the greatest gift a leader
gives to the organization is to make it
sustainably healthy and what were you
thinking is you were going that would
you consider that the the toughest thing
that you dealt with in life or was this
just another business challenge or what
was your mindset because
a lot of these people are entering
stages where they're starting to deal
with some of these real PL personnel
they're leading teams they're you know I
saw the resumes a lot of these women and
they're at that stage you've just been
through a crucible yeah what was your
was this a major life setback for you
was it and how do you think about it I
mean I'll go back to what I said earlier
one of the things I learned from Kent is
it's in the periods of adversity that
you can get the most done so it wasn't
easy in fact Laura peels out here
somewhere she was my chief of staff at
the time and she remembers she was in
those rooms at times when you know I had
hate videos about me on YouTube
literally where there I went on we were
in an ube live we're at 15,000 angry
community members and I go on and I hear
one of them a cost of one of our
employees and I was on YouTube so I go
on YouTube and I put an eBay in the
first video is what John Donahoe is
doing to eBay and I click it on and I
had over a hundred thousand views I
click it on and it scenes from
Schindler's List where that German and
they put Donahoe is shooting the Jew and
they put a big community member so I
can't tell you that it was easy and
Laura can attest to that what I can tell
you is I had some sense and some
experience frankly I all my leadership
opportunities I took over the Bain San
Francisco office when the firm was
bankrupt I took over a bain and and it
was in the biggest it was in this calm
crash so I've had some experience about
early in your leadership tenure having
crisis and understanding the crisis is
an opportunity and but I think the
hardest thing is just having the the
fortitude to to stay with it and to have
the did not wish it were better but to
recognize for what it is and take
advantage of the adversity you can drive
more change in tough times you're
somewhat known for having taken time off
from Bain you know to be with family and
to deal with sort of first things first
did that help you
that experience contributed to your
ability to get there or was it just such
a different experience than your eBay
experience that it wasn't relevant to I
mean I want you to kind of explore this
yeah this time off with family and
because you've set priorities in a way
that is probably known by most of the
people in the room where you left well I
get married at a young age and I was
married when I came to Stanford and
actually we had a we had a our first
child was born the first day of first
term finals so it was a it was a really
transformative experience for me because
I showed up with an excuse of why I
didn't have to do well and that first
term you remember first term first year
everyone's freaking out and I'm like I'm
having a baby it doesn't really matter I
don't have to do well and you know I
took that pressure off myself and I
actually enjoyed it and sure enough jack
my son who's now 26 25 was born the
first term
Maureen McNichols was my first final and
we had a baby that night and I was
relaxed that week I got five H's I don't
know if they still grade the same way
that fall term it was bizarre and what
it taught me was a little perspective
your family can give you perspective
that actually contributes to your
effectiveness as a leader you talked
about the same thing as well about how
the things outside of leadership my
family my kids family crises family
experiences without a doubt have been
some of the biggest contributors to my
effectiveness as a leader I want to know
how many times Eileen had to pull out
that Shawmut bank receipt and remind you
of it's in tatters because she's done so
many times so Kent would you just share
an example of a tough choice you've had
to make as a leader and how you've gone
about it and implemented it and you know
just reflect on something that's been a
tough a tough call for you well I think
typically the toughest ones well I'll do
that I changed my example I was going to
talk about terminating people
that you like but I'll switch to a
different one a few years ago we did a
3.1 billion dollar acquisition of a
competitor in our same space and so
there was lots of overlap we do dialysis
centers it's when your kidney doesn't
work and so there's lots of overlap and
the FTC was going to insist that we
divest some and because because we had
regard to something a very tight culture
the divita village teammates and
citizens of the village that the
Assumption unspoken assumption among a
lots of virtually all divita people is
that we would never divest one of our
native centers we've been only divest
from the company that we were acquiring
and I made and that's in fact what a
majority the executives voted and I
overruled that and divested some of our
centers with people who loved to beated
entirely and thought they had been a
part of turning around the company
because it was a mess when when we first
arrived they felt that I had absolutely
violated this social contract and going
in front of those people and the other
people who were not invested in
explaining why I did that was brutal I
mean just having adults come up some
angry saying very painful things some
just just crying just crying and crying
and when the worst ones actually the
ones who said I understand why you have
to do this but I'm so sad and crying and
crying and knowing that you were
changing their lives and the company
that they were going with is not going
to be the same as the company that I was
kicking them out of that which is a lot
of what you've heard
eBay oh absolutely I mean Drive driving
necessary yet painful change is one of
the hardest things a leader so what's
your self-talk when you do something
like that you know you know you're doing
the right thing or at least you
according to every analysis you've done
in your head in your heart tell you
you've got to do it but it's still
brutal let's just I'll tell you what I
told the people we used the metaphor
where the community first in a company
second we use that for making decisions
and we use our mission statement for
making decisions
and I sat with people and stuff it was
you would be saying the that coming day
when you say you're not gonna work it to
beat anymore because you're retiring or
because your spouse is transferred or
because you get a great opportunity
maybe even at a competitor and so you're
gonna say to me Katie
I've loved to be that I've learned so
much here but it's right for me to go
from my family's life for my spouse's
life for my life it's it's time for me
not to work at divita anymore it's been
great
similarly therefore it most of life in
areas like this needs to be symmetrical
we cannot make a lifetime commitment to
an individual because they can't do it
for us and my job is to secure the
long-term viability of the village and
and therefore in order to keep the
village as strong as possible for the
most people therefore I must make this
decision which is very bad for you just
like you leaving me when you're the best
facility administrator we've ever had
and with you leaving that Center a lot
of the patients are gonna go into
doctors gonna switch that's bad for us
but we wish you the best because you're
making an honorable decision consistent
with with your values and and so it was
one of those cases where he had we not
had the foundation of the real metaphor
and of the values we believed in there's
no way it could have been persuasive
because it would have been just a
capitalistic decision you know is that a
metaphor you use or the similar how did
you go about it it you know joy those
are the loneliest moments right and and
and and those are the moments where the
head is your enemy and you're your you
have to trust your intuition and your
instinct and to some extent I would view
where all of you are think of the next
10 15 20 years as learning laboratories
to build and grow your intuition your
emotional intelligence your intelligence
your instincts your judgment because in
those moments you can't ask you can
you've got to go inside
and you got to say what do I think's
right and I have to believe in it even
in the face of what can be a lot of
negative feedback and you can go ask
your friends or counselors aboard for
advice but at the end of the day the job
of the leader is to make
that decision and the hard decisions are
the ones that are in the face of
adversity and so so I you know and there
and there's always a little doubt there
as a leader you can always show the
doubt you've got to say oh this is what
we're gonna do and this is where we're
going but but I I think one of the most
important things you can do in your
careers is build your judgment build
your instincts and that doesn't just
come from business it comes from from
life because you'll be called upon
you'll be called upon relying on those I
mean Laura knows that there are tough
times to know you know we were gonna say
him you know we're gonna lay off 10% of
the company never been laid off before
that was if I had to waver one bit we
wouldn't have done it everyone else
wanted to find a way out and and and
those are lonely moments so is this
group in here you said take the 10 that
next 10 15 years develop yourself
develop emotional intelligence ability
to lead people study leadership etc if
you project forward 15 years for you
guys you know the next chapter you know
I sense that you both enjoy being CEOs
now even though you've been in CEO hell
it's still a job you like let's be clear
it moved out of hell about 15 years 15
months ago okay
I've gotten a little better so so your
breakup you look like you're dead you
clear your liking the job now so 15
years from now what's it what's the next
year whatever it is I don't know how
long but the next chapter you have you
given much thought
I mean ken is an intentional guy you've
kind of point you've had a career path
what's the next job you're both young
yeah I say young my age you really young
I think we'd be working together I mean
as long as I'm not working for you
like revenge revenge would be too sweet
so let me ask my know you know for me
it's it's again the three principles how
do we how do how do we build how can I
be part of building something that's
special enduring doing it with people
that that I want to be doing it with and
in a way we're how we do it is as
important as what we're doing and and I
think at that stage in my life it's
going to be more about who I'm doing
things with and then picking out the
world problems that we're applying our
energies toward and I can go ahead not
even mean to duck the answer for me I'm
sort of rewording my own own life well
mission statement and in Freni when I
stopped doing this I would like to be
very involved in not-for-profit cause of
some sort we're working on it is team
oriented because that's what I love
where there's significant controversy
around it so it's a it's a battle II
it's a full contact sport not a not a
game of checkers and and we're whether
we succeed or fail
everybody will at the end say they're
really glad they were in that fight
that's those are my four criteria with
what comes next for me thank you Jolie
you mentioned on on the way in your good
friends with Mitt Romney and if there
was ever a business leader it should be
political leader it's Kenter yeah you
know so anyone that's from Colorado
I think he should be the next governor
and well I was just going to say meet
the 46th president yeah amen so last
question for me and then we're going to
open up the last 20 minutes or so to the
audience to ask whatever questions you
like I think we have mics here but if
you each had a mulligan if you had a
do-over you know and I'm assuming you
haven't done everything exactly as you'd
want if you had a do-over what would it
be what would you like to take another
shot at obviously not your first quarter
of your first year at the GSB
anybody'd love to have those grades
requirements cars I don't think we had
62 over two years there's a lot tougher
on the East Coast yeah I won't compare
my first term grades yeah the you know
it's what your mind go is quickly is
those things that didn't go well and
what I'm caught and I can't give you a
good answer because I now realize what I
would not realize then that the stuff
that went really poorly helped me grow
in ways where I don't think some of the
good stuff that's happened would have
ever happened and so and so I if I was
maybe right before that moment I would
still wouldn't pick to do it again I
can't say that but I actually don't I
worry that if some of those really bad
experiences had not happened my life
wouldn't be as healthy now so I don't
have a good answer there's that quote by
Ralph Waldo Emerson's is when its
darkest men see the Stars and so I've
often thought that adversity you know is
really a great teacher you wouldn't wish
it on yourself but you wouldn't want to
have missed it I mean somewhat similarly
I it's when I didn't trust my instincts
or I was afraid of failure or afraid of
the consequence so when I first got to
Ebay was before I was CEO I came in and
it's like I think we need to change some
things here there was no you don't
understand you don't understand you
don't understand and and I put my
instincts on the side for a couple years
and just that I must not understand I
want to keep learning and in hindsight I
was not trusting my instincts and I was
afraid of the consequence of coming in
that environment making causing
disruption making change and failing and
you know by the time I got to CEO it was
had to do it it was so obvious but yeah
and it's so fear failure for me would be
a trusting my instincts to not be afraid
to fail so I've got a number of other
questions several of them revolve around
this issue here's a couple of
consultants when actually did consulting
the for Business School and after
business school came up to write and
then have ended up as CEOs I know a lot
of you are currently consulting have
been consultants cetera so maybe a
number of questions around that but I
want you to feel free to ask any
questions and so do we have the mics and
the setup for that and just raise your
hand and we'll pass the mics in here
we've got a hand here in the in the
middle if we can pass that down hi hi
I'm Fernando class of 2005 set a
question regarding the points that you
both made about starting at the end or
the thumb stone and when we were talking
about that I couldn't help reminding the
speech that we had in in our graduation
by Steve Jobs when he talked about
connecting the dots and how sometimes
you just have to make a decision that
doesn't necessarily make a lot of sense
but it feels that it's right and then
only afterwards looking back you can
sort of connect the dots and have a
story that sort of makes more sense to
you do you how do you deal with this do
you ever have to make a decision that
felt right but doesn't necessarily
seemed like a step towards the goal that
you just had to you just felt like it
was it was the right thing to do but it
doesn't necessarily move too towards
what you're aiming for I'll take one
stab at it back when I when I first came
to divita it was a company with it's a
lost 90% of its market value was
functionally bankrupt being investigated
by the SEC sued by shareholders mostly
executives have been fired or quit
because of all the above and
and and so it it it well there was a lot
of reasons not to do it what felt right
was to say right from the beginning
we're gonna try to create a special
place and used words around team and
creating the greatest Alice's company of
world has ever seen
so that's that felt right but there are
a lot of reasons why that well
analytically one could argue it wasn't
the right time because you knew the life
people gonna say how stupid to talk
about that when we might not make
payroll I was stupid to talk about that
when most of us think you're gonna fix
this and spin it and sell it and make a
lot of money and leave and so I knew
that if the group was going to be like
this and about twenty percent we're
gonna react positively and the other
eighty percent were going to be quite
negative some vehemently negative and so
I and I wrestled with that intensely
over six months as that played out two
or three times a week in different
settings until enough people crossed the
philosophical bridge and decided that
they were gonna try for the same thing
and so that was one of those cases where
it it just sort of felt right and as
there's stage in life right said this is
what I'm which I might not have had the
courage to do when I was younger that
I'm gonna do it and then only later did
it start to come together because it was
like you could lay out an entire work
plan only later could you connect the
dots that came from stumbling in the
direction that felt spiritually correct
I remember that decision when you
decided to go to divita that was well I
thought you were gonna mention that when
he had toughest decision and almost cost
me my marriage so that yeah it was but
don't we all struggle with intuition you
know versus analysis I mean here you're
learning analysis but you really do have
an intuition about some things and it's
getting the point where you can trust
that so back to the audience here hands
hi I have a question that both of you
referred to somewhat obliquely and for
those of us who are maybe 10 years
rather than five years out and in a dual
working family can you talk a little bit
about how you and your part
have navigated that through time and how
that stage of life for your where you
are now what might you have been
thinking about 10 years out in that
regard surely I mean we share one thing
we both married women who are a lot
smarter better-looking and more talented
the I let me just I'll I'll tell you how
we've done it and then you can do the
same so you know I went to college with
my wife we both went to Dartmouth she's
appear she's a partner we came here to
Stanford I started Business School we
had her first kid
she started law school the next fall I
went to the Dean at the time Bob jet
aqui who said I could go part-time in my
second year of Business School which
didn't turn out to be necessary but
again mentally I was going part-time
because we lived over in Escondido
village for five years while she
finished her degree she got done with
law school clerked for a federal judge I
walked into Kent and Tom Tierney said I
gotta quit bein you remember this
first-year farm was fund as a client
they said what are you talking about I
said I've got to drive my kids to school
every morning because my wife has to be
in the judge's chambers at 7:30 in the
morning so I cannot travel one day I've
got to be there every single day they
said fine you can go part-time what are
you crazy even go part-time so I worked
part-time for a year while Eileen was
clerking for a judge in San Francisco
and we had two young kids ironically the
client loved it and it worked out well
we were dual-career for a number of
years until we had our third and fourth
children which point she stopped working
and and did a PhD I did a sabbatical
there at one point and did a sabbatical
for three months - and you know today
she's a US ambassador Human Rights
Council
based in Geneva and we still have we
have two kids out of college into at
home so and it's been a partnership in a
journey it's been and it's been a
constant dialogue in a constant effort
where we both had certain things we
cared about it's it
it's the intentionality point Kent
talked about about personal life and
there were many times where on paper
what we were trying to do wouldn't have
made sense but we had a shared
commitment toward our children share
commitment toward our family you
remember I remember one of the just
occurred to me after we had our third
and fourth kids I cancelled our social
life remember that yes and we we
literally I we told everybody we're
canceling our social life for a few
years because we didn't want our friends
to feel bad that we were always going to
say no because we were going to say you
know what are our careers and our family
is all we can handle right now
and so you know it's been a journey it's
been a an enormous and rewarding journey
there's never been a right or wrong
answer and we've had to work at it every
day and we work at it with our kids now
you know what happens is your kids
provide your social life is it my social
life standing on the sides of basketball
courts or water polo
I mean 95% social life some around my
kids or the parents of my kids friends
so it comes back in but just in a
different form if I can add a few points
to such an incredibly important question
first by way of context so my wife and I
met first year of business school at
Harvard and she went into venture
capital I went to Bain as she became one
of the first female venture capital
partners in America and this is back in
the days when literally we delayed
getting pregnant the first time until
she was promoted because we were worried
if she got pregnant first there would be
no promotion the so it was a very
intense set of compromises and I and and
you end up kind of take it one year or
one chunk at a time you can either it
just has to be that way once we had our
second child she stopped working she
went from full to part two then not
she's now sits in the board of three
large public
companies Medtronic and USA are in
Calpine and a number of not-for-profit
boards and it served 15 years in the
Stanford Board of Trustees and ended up
with this life which she actually
preferred to had she stayed full-time in
venture capital as a mommy as a person
as a citizen but at the time we were
both petrified because it felt like she
was going off a cliff into some sort of
professional abyss versus what she was
doing as a high profile venture capital
partner and and we stole the idea john
told me had this idea about what we call
a social moratorium and and we did and
we did the same math which we used to go
out one night a week with friends maybe
maybe that's two nights every third week
so one point three nights a week and
when you can touch Ken right and when
you when you cancel that it's an amazing
surge in high quality weekend time with
your kids and so we went 15 years we're
just were empty nesters we just became
mighty nesters and and Denise and I are
going how do you actually I call people
and invite them because long ago we
stopped being invited so we're getting
back into it and we but we had to
customize things that when I took over
to Vita my wife said when we're not
going to move to LA and the company was
headquartered down there it can't kids
are happy here my parents are here so
much of my boards are here so I was
going to commute in San Francisco in LA
and it is kind of my god we said okay
let's go ahead and try it and if it
fails I'll find a successor and no harm
done for a year or two and we found two
things out there port well first what
happened very shortly because I was
forced to because I so much want to be
home I started working two days a week
at home and then only being down in LA
two nights a week which was less than I
traveled that bait and so you would have
never thought of that but once you were
in the situation just like going
part-time and doing these other things
if you sit down and say okay we got to
solve for something let's let's try a
bold experiment at the worst since I
really love this job the worst that can
happen is they tell me okay you're at
home too much your fight but they didn't
and so I got to have have it all because
I was doing them at the school is when
they got home and the two nights I was
down there I got to work 17 hours a day
get amazing things done take people out
to dinner but I never would have had
that idea
had we given up and not and not gone for
it and the final thing I was saying this
subject cause it's so important is we
made a deal early on our marriage is
gonna sound really try to some of you
that no matter how mad we were before we
went to sleep we would kiss each other
and say that we loved each other and
there were times only almost you know
spat out the words but it's still if you
end that way it's really good for the
next morning do we get the mics hi Dave
from class of 2009 you guys both spoke
to the importance of experiential
learning and I'm just wondering if you
have any tricks that you can share with
us for how to find time to think and
reflect and kind of organize all the
data points that you get each day each
week each month in each year you got to
make it no one's gonna give it to you no
one's gonna give it to you so you know
in my case I use early-morning because
that's the time I'm most reflective and
and and least tired and you know whether
it's prayer whether its reflection
whether it's journaling I think you
might have started me on journaling and
you know I'm not I'm not a an obsessive
journaler but but if I go a month and I
haven't spent I haven't written out kind
of what's going on for a couple days
that's a sign that I really need it and
so the other thing I'll say and I think
we both share this is and I learned this
at Stanford we were talking about this I
think some of the best one of the best
courses I took at Stanford was a
leadership course Jim March took and we
read Warren piece a fellow
and a corinna and I forget what the
fourth was Don Quixote yes Don Quixote
talk about I've choked it at windmills
many times in my career some of the best
leadership learning I've done has been
reading what a character is religious
books by Jesuits by Buddhists can buy
and and and so the more you go along in
life including on some of the life
balance issues looking outside what
might be a business tradition can often
be the greatest source of reflection and
learning and what I would add although
it's largely redundant there's a
Buddhist quote one cannot pour from an
empty cup and so you must discover for
you what ways to keep your cup full your
family's cup full and the people that
work with you their cups full and for me
I do personal journaling to be once a
week and I kept to keep track as if I
don't keep track of what I'm doing it or
not I sometimes slip for a few weeks and
I've got six categories right body write
thought right family right friends right
work and right plan and I just find I
can't lie to myself as much if I just
had to write two sentences about the
week if I'm just talking glibly to
myself while I'm driving or getting
dressed I can convince myself a little
you know you can yourself
yes and so that and that really works I
think I'm much more ISIL myself when I
see myself writing a sentence on a piece
of paper about how I behave that that
week and and then also I try to make
sure that a couple of times a year I get
24 hours 18 24 hours totally by myself
in a quiet place I'm backpack often be
in a tent or like a little cabin the
mountains go up but just be totally with
myself for a long time to kind of work
my way through whatever conventional
wisdoms I've developed about my life and
that just for me takes a certain amount
of quiet time without conventional
interruption I mean your friends can be
a big help as well on that so Kent and I
worked intensely together for what
probably six seven eight years and now
we see each other three times a year
four times a year but within two minutes
of seeing each other he's asking me he
doing any prayer you're doing any
journaling what's going on in your and
and the questions not how how are your
kids doing in basketball and it's it's a
did we hold each other accountable in
that way or there's there's a and what
when we get together I know I
better have thought about something cuz
he's going to be probing about what's
going on and and so and our friendship
that's one of the extraordinary things
about our friendship is we can not have
seen each other in six months and it
takes two minutes and we're in at that
level so reach out to your friends and
ask them to help you the accountable in
that way I think if I can add one other
thing in this so this is where it
becomes so important to being a company
or organization which is relatively
aligned with the high you wanna love
your life and it doesn't mean that
for-profit means the way in which people
interact with each other because there's
some people they have work that drain so
much out of their cup every week it's
really hard to refill it if you're in a
place where again it can have two
companies in the same industry one could
be in a place where people interact with
each other and care about each other and
and do things for the community as a
company and do things for each other and
there's a sense of shared values and
shared commitment the all within the
real world of budgets
capitalistic preferences and and that
that same job with the same financial
performance is far less draining of your
cup so I submit that's where this I was
worried when people talk about their
professional in their personal lives I
say if those are two separate then
there's probably something wrong with
your professional life so let's take one
more question of the eyes then I've
gotten a final question and we'll wrap
up here on time but one last question
out here from the audience I was seized
the initiative at Julian clasp very v
I'm interested I often hear that it's
very difficult for consultants to
transition into a line management role
and particular into a CEO role you've
both achieved that with spectacular
success I'm curious to know whether
you'd have achieved that anyway or
whether there are particular things
you've taken from consulting that have
made you successful CEOs today the first
yeah we talked about this briefly
earlier so I left Bain at 35 became
president of a public company and had
the CEO and chairman not been a very
wise gentle supportive kind man I would
have been fired in the first year so
because I was trying to drive too much
change I was too sure I was right and so
I screwed it up pretty badly and got
saved by playing in the right arena not
by playing well the my experience having
said that I love a lot of the skills
that Bain consulting gave me that have
helped me be a better executive but when
I first made the transition I had
certain muscles which were very over
developed and other muscles which were
very underdeveloped and and they were
equal problems and what I did wrong
despite all that consulting teaches you
about listening and facilitating is once
I stepped into an operating leadership
role
I was tuned intent on proving how much
value I could add as opposed to proving
how much I respected and would listen to
other people there's a old saying that
they don't care how much you know - they
know
should care well I was way too antenna
demonstrating how much I knew and how
much value I can add and what should be
different as opposed to demonstrating
that I respected them cared for them and
together we could do great things so I I
screwed it up pretty badly I screwed up
worse you know I think which probably
similars we both knew we wanted to be
leaders I think it has far more to do
about you and what is in your purview
and ambition and then you know coming to
Stanford was a place I took advantage of
the leadership resources Jim March
course the touchy-feely the creativity
course the hell love it was around then
into a great course Bain was a vehicle
for me to learn a lot about leadership
and I ended up running an office as a
first year partner and running the firm
at 38 39 years old and and getting a lot
of good experience and and coming to
eBay I've learned a lot about leadership
so I'd be really careful about the label
consultants or not consultants it's sort
of like the label Stanford or Harvard
you know many of you could have gone to
either place it's much more a question
of what you make of the experience and
if if you want to run something
consulting firms a great place to learn
some good skills it needs to shape how
you what kinds of things you tend to
work on how you get involved just as
going I was hearing about the divita
redwood program which is a program Kent
put in place that sounds phenomenal
where I guess now over 50 Harvard and
Stanford MBAs have joined divita in a
leadership track that helps develop
Stanford and Harvard MBAs in line
environments to grow their leadership
skills the program is just a vehicle the
people's what take advantage of it or
they don't and so I wouldn't let anyone
tell you though you're a consultant you
can't run something that's any
more than someone that works at GE can
necessarily run something well after
five years much more to do about the
individual and
mindset and your attitude and that's
something you want to do find
environments where you can learn and
make sure you learn so here's the last
question Kent if it's your 50th birthday
where would you want to go and what
would you want to do would you could go
anywhere in your 50th birthday where
would you like to be well that was four
years ago can you remember back then so
I can tell you what we did which was
because it was a special like any
anniversary like a reunion it's these
are society's vehicles for forcing
reflection
that's why tribes religious societies
have holidays and other rituals it's to
provoke rough reflection and and so it
did for us and what I chose to do which
we worked out beautifully is we took
three and a half weeks off in the summer
I did virtually zero work we took my
parents and my wife's parents my
children and all of my siblings that
could go to Europe for many of them it
was their first time probably the only
time in their life that get to go for
our parents we knew it would be their
last time and we have lost one of them
since then and we did part of it as the
full tribe in Italy renting a big home
and doing glorious things part of it
just as a nuclear family myself my
children and a little barge and then and
then my wife and I would the finish and
it was just 25 days of sort of
celebration of family family tribe it
was glorious and in their family still
talks about it is one of those special
special times because many folks in our
family couldn't afford it so we funded
the whole thing so John it is your 50th
birthday where would you most like he's
going home to take care he's going home
to take care of the kids mommy's in
Geneva
it's true you know this is gonna be a
little bit I'm gonna go low before we
end high but it there's a there's a
message in it so first of all being here
with Kent means a lot to me if I were to
think about a sense of purpose and
meaning and people that mean a lot to my
life I can't think of a better way I'm
gonna go pick up my son and get him to a
basketball tournament that's a great
thing and then a tragedy happened in my
broader ecosystem earlier this week a
some very good friends we grew up with
their third child our kids grew up with
their third child was a sophomore at
University Center Cruz and at 3 a.m. on
Saturday night he slipped off a
skateboard hit his head and died it's
brain dead and so I'm going to the
memorial tonight I'll be an usher and
it's it it is a really heavy thing as a
parent the 3 a.m. phone call is the
thing as we all know is what you just
read and especially when they don't live
at home because and yet I know in the
pain and in the suffering there will be
such a sense of community and communion
and and connection to what life's really
about that it's not a celebration
although they're calling it a
celebration of his death of his life
there is death but those kinds of
experiences if I had that versus going
to a party it's not even close I'm
horrified it happened but I'm I'm not
afraid of going in fact I embrace it
because I think I think the painful
moments in life or some of the best both
as a leader we talked about diversity
and then and then personally so well I
did meet a donor but all I can tell you
is as you go on and like crisis happens
it happens to yourself happens to your
family happens to your kids and I think
one of the things we learn to do is
embrace it because it there's so much
that comes out of it and it makes you a
better person and a better leader too so
let me just say on behalf of all of
those here that we're so glad that you
were willing to spend part of your 50th
birthday with us here and we want to
wish you a happy birthday
so I think is I think we've got Beth
I'm gonna miss I'm gonna pop out
of a cake somewhere if I can just say
you know you know see all the words
after this session after this session
when you become 50 I can't even see the
cake with that just want to say you can
now see after experiencing Donahoe for
90 minutes why I knew I had to leave
Bain because my fragile ego couldn't
deal with the fact that I knew he was
gonna rock it past me so I got off that
highway onto a country road and just to
get the last word in John does have to
leave so if we could all just let him
have a clear path out
I think Kent can hang around a little
bit and then we'll let everybody leave
and in 15 minutes will any of you who'd
like to talk about what we just talked
about here feel free to gather in up
here at the front and I'll conduct a
little bit of a I think it's here isn't
it yeah it's here in this room so with
that let's let John go